the Biden Administration decided to
deport the Rica family they've been
living in the state of Tennessee for the
past 15 years this is a family that has
not committed any crime so what did they
do well back in 2006 you and Hannah lore
Romo were living in Germany and they
decided they wanted to homeschool their
five children because they're Christians
and they were upset about the perverted
and satanic books and curriculum that
their kids were being forced to read and
were being subjected to in schools but
in Germany homeschooling was not allowed
so the Rach family had a decision to
make and to protect their children you
and Hanah Micah fled to the United
States back in 2008 now after this
decision was made to deport the family
and after it was upheld in courts there
was an enormous public outcry as you
might imagine so the DHS under the Obama
Administration did something unexpected
they allowed the ricas to stay in this
country but then on September 6th of
this year during a routine check-in the
ricas learned that their deferred status
was coming to an end for some reason the
Biden administration had decided that
they were going to terminate that status
and they weren't given a reason